so many guns
alright so hey we can go straight
through here now right because we've got
already
so it's mr. X Ted
like do we is he nothing anymore I think
he is you know it's so interested in
that because if he is and that doesn't
really coincide with tails did I just
hear and liquor I guess I can
I don't want to have her to liquor I
mean I can see this guy here here's
something you're nice where are you yeah
just come out here come on up zombie
Nazy
one down how many more to go I can hear
you
where the [ __ ] are you CeCe
oh I remember this you are feasting at
me you've seen this so many times
stop acting confused both her and Chris
does my head in right of course of
course of course of course she's not
actually that she's playing I can't be
bothered you know I can't but by the
ladder
see I kept you alive when I was Chris
but now that I'm Claire I can't be
bothered
that song thumb went quite a lot of
boom-boom
yes it did zom some oh my gosh I get it
[Music]
because we were calling yours are and
now now there are zones ons here this
looks like I know doesn't wait yeah it
looks like a hot sauce bottle that I've
got in my cupboard downstairs when the
game is so relatable give me my knife
back I'm in my head
pick up summer stuff it should come in
handy
okay so needs fun nothing again
oh cool
this is for my spark gun so didn't have
any ammo for it so that's cool
don't go back up please stay down there
oh yeah
don't do this again confine it tip me
over tip me a little bit this home last
time to remember to do that what look at
him
back up
he's waiting for me to return this what
does he know
Jimmy your presence is urgently
requested by chief karma in the east
area you okay you hung him in there I
feel like I should dispose of some
things I was out of ammo for the Sparky
but not anymore
wait which one's mine yeah I don't I
don't want this one
so I guess I can use this again with me
sure
wait oh is this just an upgrade for it
oh damn I still have no ammo for it so I
got told to save my poison my acid
grounds s1 my asset rounds for sometime
in the future and I don't exactly quite
know what for but I'll save them I'll
bite so now if I should just keep I'm
just gonna keep this with me anyway and
then hope that I find a Mer along the
way I probably should say
and now I can go back already
I've got it right away well let's do
that then
so the antiviral agents in the West area
yeah let's go back no holding back and
hopefully our friend hasn't made it into
the hallway nah he's not that clever
good this one's still down
[Music]
this is
OSs oh wait yeah I remember any time
should you do it to it
do it to it he near muff
there we go and now a zombies gonna come
[Music]
I thought its head exploded oh my god I
couldn't see no I can't see
[Music]
what no just keep going great
[Music]
yes some this is an r2d2 Cup
it's huge access
[Music]
right I hope we get through this a
little bit quicker than it took Chris
just cause by in these points it's a
little bit annoying cuz you are kind of
doing the same thing again but it's okay
alright well give you what you want
cuz I've got a bunch of green herbs in
there anyway
hi grenade ammo hey has anyone been
watching that like robots and I don't
remember the name it's like a robots and
something on Netflix and everybody's
talking about it and I'm going to use
like what is it tell me and should I
watch it because I haven't even looked
on Netflix in the longest time and
whenever I go on there my go to is just
Steven universe just like happy as I
step on the background what does this in
this make I can't remember handgun ammo
my acid rounds all combined two of these
mixes submachine oh maybe I'll make some
more acid rounds for the parent you need
and yeah but a point in the game that
I'm not too sure I've got eight here so
I might as well get out one BB gun
it's got flame round in it and they've
got some acid Browns
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's beautiful man again I remember the
last time we were here we're watching a
mr. X out there like hey so I wonder
what weapon would be best
let's see how you react in a bit of acid
where'd you come from and they come from
somewhere around here don't do it do you
yes where are those hello oh that worked
the music is so intense for how
nonchalantly I just kind of walked
through that okay
dispensing solution now loved us and
robots that's the one Justin yes you
look emo today it's cuz I'm all in black
I am an emo I might want to keep your
plant rounds cuz the fire people well
the the other ones seem to work pretty
well on them too but yeah fire worked
pretty well last time didn't it um keep
the ass advance of Birkin okay well I've
still got eight back in my books anyway
so that's it I'm pretty pretty good feel
pretty good maybe wait changed my [ __ ] I
want
hello
oh yeah I gotta find the other oh yeah
this is when I started to draw on my
hand and then I got loads of comments
like why don't you just take a picture
on your phone because I still have the
mentality of a 12 year old running out
of place to store things I know I really
am I could make some more acid rounds
yeah sure why not
apparently I need them so cool I've got
a red herb
[Music]
do I need to write this down no I will
take a picture on my phone this time
yes I know I can hear you behind me you
want to kill me that's fine just let me
take a picture this
cool now we'll run backwards bulls
sorry
why did you sound like the girl from the
grudge okay this one this is actually
much better than me writing on my hand
because sometimes I wouldn't write it
right and then I get confused yeah no
article enter DUP dip-dip dip-dip
dip-dip dip-dip dip-dip dip-dip dip-dip
dip-dip dip-dip enter thank you go back
you already knew the route here we we
said hello to them just now
[Applause]
[Music]
down we go
sounds like this it means to you to keep
me dude
sorry I've grown up okay I just do it
cuz like all the cool kids did it okay I
need to go so some of this stuff oh wait
yeah I forget they change damn it oh
wait I know look as we're here before
they might still be here now and this
room was horrendous cuz there was so
many zombies
I'm sorry I'm not reading most of Texas
because I already read them before when
I was Leon so that's my point and if
you've been watching then you have read
them too okay so I guess I'll just
combine these two any liquors around you
we go no Lucas Lucas
I know you're alive don't be messing
with me boys
get up get up no seriously
earth
are you gonna get up now
No
oh my god she stood right by one okay I
am very confused didn't notice about
that
sure let's just make oh my god more I
guess yeah I'm definitely sticking with
this gun for a little bit he's up
somebody MA oh my gosh yep
oh hello fantastic okay and then we can
actually oh great
like a flash grenade got to nine got so
much stuff anyone would think I'm
actually relatively not part of this
game
why because I'm good at running away
from zombies I think that's what I've
done
no I'll keep this blue have I got mix
mix of how many Reds if I got
[Music]
9-millimeter I don't think I have any
bullets for you do I
No I might as well just be zero
oh my god we have another knife
hey Joe don't worry so I'll never grow
up I'm basically P upon ok I'm still
very skeptical about my situation here
but we'll roll with it
told you I freaking knew it
yes and now I don't have to worry about
you anymore
[Music]
wait I thought I was quiet that's how it
normally goes that wasn't fair
I instinctively stopped myself running
because I knew the liquors thank you for
subscribing examine uh-huh well sure
take a picture I guess cuz then I can go
put that back in thing Wow
if I want to go back there's a second
look at that now
Cheers
heydo Mila - Mila Tamela dr. leap
this lady probably is so I've read all
of these yeah just really though what a
great gal oh that one now yeah she
attacked my parka Oh scheisse why am I
here already I shouldn't be here there's
something I've got to do before this oh
yeah I've got it like find the solution
before I freeze it right I shouldn't
really be here yet I've got to open that
thing in the room with the plaque hello
what the hell are you in the freezer I
think so okay
or are you back out here I think you're
in the freezer okay Wow anyway
don't come near me
yeah I warned him
[Music]
I'm ready look at him he's about to fall
I knew you were gonna fall I saw you I
know your pranks bulbus so let me go
give me a sword shield actually can
[Music]
which one are you wait
you're not even working okay
oh the sun's SMG is a great deal for the
licky licky that's true because they
won't be able to hear it
I never even thought of that who said
that
thanks Sam I love the fact that you seem
shy sir
yeah I don't know it just kind of comes
out I even think about it
I love your videos young man young man
oh that's cute I think I was a typo for
this cute thank you thank you very much
who said that uh oh no it's gone up the
chat I can't see it
tell me it was you and I'll say thank
you um let's go back to the box okay how
do I put the thing in the things like
how
[Music]
wait I haven't warm I sit on so I
already have 10 min imagine what I'm
over doc its alas machine
thanks for subscribing
Oh yo no Yolo renascence thank you
behind this Sun mmm
it'd be nice if I had a few more open
slots I guess I can't just leave my
knife here okay save again and go back
around let's try and figure out oh wait
well we have that code on the back of
the medal actually nice so let's get out
oh wait where's my other gun
hmm
I want short cut please thank you but I
also want this one so [ __ ] delayed
reaction
it's like ow wait no I'll seriously
outweigh let's get my picture up hey
Roble 46 full-time and new cats why'd
you look shy that I don't know I said it
in school once and I thought like I was
cool cuz it wasn't English and it's just
stuck by school I mean I was like 14
years old
what no that was what it said try again
it was yeah it was
oh wait no yeah this one maybe it's a
smaller line this one cuz these two a
quiet like right once chunky one smaller
and they is this what kid I mean this
one's definitely
mom just wait no let me do it again
right struggling in Tibet coding like
this yes this is the one great is it my
rebel phase yeah I think
hey we got it okay you know what we
forgot we forgot the vial we didn't we
definitely don't have a do it yeah okay
let's go back I must have put it just
getting started
no thanks you know renascence asked you
engage adjust amount a solution to match
cartridge capacity that's probably bit
too much yeah
wait no go back the other way
[Music]
[Music]
but then it I just want like the tiniest
bit so me too much maybe I'll die with
this one
I'm stuck with that stupid amount again
okay hold up
let me put you in this one
[Music]
this is hard remember this being easier
last time guess we got time they'll be
there that's gonna be too much though
isn't it is it you reckon if I put this
in there do you think
that's not gonna be enough
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I think I might be getting mad do
you think this do you think this finally
[Music]
thank you guys liking Second Life yeah
he's calming myself
it's a ninety sick great now we can go
to the frozen room fantastic
say hi to our friends that never die
the leafy being carnations of the brunch
okay there's a litter of yeah yeah
that there is he lick lick lick
I hope there's two actually yeah 30 and
these we killed all of our zombie
friends so at least you don't have to
worry about that as we very much killed
them I'm going okay great
yeah I foresee a zombie jumping out of
the refrigerators freezers once we've
done this but we will do it anyway okay
I'm out of here and then we'll go back
we'll go pack pack pack pack of it which
way do we go yeah that's cool past ah
let's go this way and then we'll go back
in the other way so we can clear the
route just in case something happens
when we insert this because last time
mr. X came so I'm very intrigued to see
I mean he should in theory be dead
should but I mean this is a Resident
Evil game he is mr. X
you know delete dramatic death
so anything we messed around here okay
well good we are okay let's put the
powder actually wait no no I wanna
change
[Music]
[Applause]
here we go okay this is a solution yeah
there we go next part to the key card so
much for the weed infestation one second
my stupid I don't know if you guys have
been my stream before but sometimes the
chat just decides hey I don't want to
scroll anymore I'm getting bored of this
scrolling so maybe game I'm just gonna
refresh it and that [ __ ] stop scrolling
again so can I see what you guys say
warning
you have dispersed a dangerous solution
our conversation your actions have been
marked and you may be subject to
disciplinary measures
you gonna get up
cool
they will get up cool ok this is what
mr. X came last time you got it
just so you know he came to here they
obviously have like a high damage count
and then it kind of stacks down because
they don't understand there being a
while okay thank you
does that mean they're in here too yeah
great yeah I feel good we're saving here
nice go back
someone asked if I was high high in life
yeah we gotta go and say Sharri that was
the name I got ourselves a new DVD to
watch that's not even a DVD it's a CD
player so old-school
I mean it's hey player what what names
okay oh okay we can pay for a little bit
longer I'm making good progress I pride
myself a WS
what did that do probably seen this
before but dr. Bergin you come along
with us quietly you think I know you
were coming this is my life's work
I'm not handing over anything we have
our orders dr. Birkin I'll ask you one
more time
we're in Italy we had a snafu I didn't
realize they said that last time that's
correct sir Roger that
[Music]
Wow ease up this should be good to go
see none of that
[Music]
I'll store you in my little box treasure
trove shower time now of course this
gonna be big big boss fight thing
did I save that there was no sage maybe
there is here
uh what am I supposed to hide Shrike
damn it I didn't know what hey this
let's listen it around for us Oh got it
uh this is not good
okay good I thought I was gonna trigger
off something got to get back to Sherry
yeah hold up just hold your horses girl
right great we have the safe point now
we have another box here we have red
herb scale stuff I'm gonna act as though
we are about to enter a boss thing so
I'm gonna get out all the stuff that I
think I might need red kumkum red and
green we can combine this
so we have anything
we'll save you putting these huh
shouldn't need that one for now
I'm taking another one out Justin gays
gun powder here and hi grenade hi
whatever this is me small I'm just gonna
live off this this gun is will be my
friend
cool okay we're ready
okay let's go
you okay fine Bulls had she need the
respond
all right so when I equip this I want
now I'm ready okay
is this hey n-word yeah I knew it
the hell is this thing that was my
husband
how does she know please not together
cuz sherry Cottam dad
[Music]
I should have killed him while I had the
chance why just you don't know why is
your husband honestly we were married to
our lips and each other
what about sharing how could you just
leave her all alone well Raccoon City
burned to help I couldn't let my
daughter grow up in a world we'd achieve
Iris's
[Music]
I got this
you should take yours
stop until it's finished trust me
fine you guys owe me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna running out of bullet how many
can you take
you got me he got me good
what oh that's my part
I
right eyes every now and then you fall
apart
[Music]
oh my god I was so cool
I'm gonna take out more ammo Oh Anna
okay boy oh yeah same problem
okay you guys said to stun him with the
big grenades and then use the guns to
the eyes is probably a good show
so that's let's do that
yeah
you will do that sounds good oh wait but
I still do need this take it all out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
good hand crazy
what are you doing
ow
[Music]
oh my god these range
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
- oh my god freakin today yeah okay Wow
we went through on normal ammo
neutralized ending ah
is now operational okay one sec I'm just
looting just finding some good stuff
Thanks the young pianist
see look how long it takes it every
night okay here opala
all the stuff that I need oh wow all
right I think I checked everything today
yeah
thanks for following
[Music]
jigmed says thank you on twitch that's
cool
gotta get back to Sherry gotta get back
to shimmy
okay I'll get back to Sherry and then
I'm gonna go have my dinner guys
so just so you know but we'll go back to
Sherry
is there any ammo in here that I left
- because so much stuff
any of this for that means we can get
right is that not for that yeah no I do
where are you there you are
this is what I meant I haven't used this
in a while something that a little
louder come up
no you will not York Merck yes I will
Jackson Jack
oh my founder hey hey my looks better
her eye looks better and
Oh how are you okay
you don't look so good
Hey look at the screen thank God so sure
he's gonna be alright
should be weak for a little while but
yes she's three of the g-virus did you
hear that try expanding this one -
sherry what happened to mommy
Oh your dad kind of turn into a monster
and killed her
take my daughter to safety
hey just leave her here you're right we
can't
[Music]
what does that mean this is self
destruct
in case the g-virus leaves the build
that stroma Tizen
[Music]
goodbye mom
[Music]
we sherry she loved you okay you really
could get going
I'm talking more about that Peter
you got a herd now
[Music]
it's like well dude you got it me share
him and it's put this in you walk faster
surely they can't be much more of the
game that what a rush you but we have to
go shorty they can't be right
you gotta be like right near the end
okay I'll see if I can finish it
upon any room in my inventory okay
is that my freedom yeah that was fine
come on
do you hear sherry let's get the hell
out of here yeah let's do it come on go
maduk pan around she's go elf ears it's
cute
yeah thank you for being so nice to me
for helping me
I'm really glad I met you really glad I
met you too sherry savior thanks until I
get you out of this place
yup
until detonation
sorry
[Music]
where we give it now
Tyron time
mr. X time no that's that's good
stupid
oh my god oh my god sorry sorry
honey two-sided yeah good let's go
come on sorry don't mind the burning
zombie sorry
[Music]
what wha-wha try
what the Train of course
how do we get in
as it does a broom here let me catch the
room
yes so mind if I do
what where the bloody hours are then
ah there you are cool
what are you doing we've got to get this
train moving I need you to stay right
here okay okay I promise I won't move
good be careful always she's a liar
this erratic
I don't go
carrying big hefty guns I wish I wasn't
strong with her
okay all right it's working we're good
Leon you're down here - yeah but the
whole place is coming down
look you need to get out fast
no I found a way out I think I think we
can all make it where are you now
clear you're still there Leon I'm sorry
you're breaking up
don't worry about me just get out of
here
Leon Leon
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
now
not react to that at all
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Wow
good
because I did god I'm here we're getting
out of here
I'll sing grubs chording the monkey
can I Drive to train
please
so it's the first thing you wanted when
we get out of here
I want to see where you live
okay hi sure
[Music]
clear Leon it's so good to see you
I told you it'd make it didn't I you did
was this this this is sherry okay Jesus
who's that I don't know you stay here
with Sherrie I'm gonna go check it out
wha there's more oh bowls I have like no
I'm uh though okay I guess let's just
use this why we can't oh wait oh thank
gosh thank goodness that this okay let's
take out do we have any like are the
colors of herbs oh we do have this one
flame round
no it's flash grenade come on man let's
get a bowl combat knife
I thought we had oh that's it then right
I guess we don't need all that
I don't think we have any more powder to
use not weird
no gosh I need the toilet
not good I'm just gonna carry on playing
yeah a little up the ante
we feel like the more anxious
I shall keep that with me I can make
bullets another one
I don't need anything
I already got knife now there yes he
told you
oh that's for my nine when I'm in that
case wait
[Music]
in the mouth
[Music]
that car
[Music]
bugger
cool I was not expecting that that was
cool asking the important questions that
I actually just met last night yeah
would have been one hell of a first date
though yeah yeah look he might be able
to give us a ride
can we trust what if it's not just a
city made sure he out of here
he has no idea who's friendly so is it
over no ah but if it's not we'll stop it
whatever it takes
yeah you damn right me well as long as
we stick together we'll be fine come on
hey you guys get a doctor me
we can get a puppy and a parent
next up on this boring Wednesday is a
song to get your blood pumping
[Music]
that was cool we finished it I don't
think we're gonna face today how I did I
see that wasn't so bad
Claire Redfield's out of sleeves alright
well thanks for watching I will I think
I still need to be upload the last one
that I played but I wasn't be upload
this and this is good because this means
now in the next live streams we can play
the next episode of life is strange to
which I've been holding up for a long
time so if you didn't want to see horror
games and you get to see something
different if you missed it I have been
playing games with my friend Amy as well
we're gonna be playing just like little
indie co-op games which have been quiet
but yeah I'm excited to play different
things with you but freaking love this
game I really did I mean I'm not gonna
lie and say
McGary mother is an evil fangirl cuz I
didn't play the originals or I did but
it was more I watched my friend play
them because my friend was super into us
and evil but I've always been I kind of
played alone in the dark a new nightmare
and then I played sunhill but I didn't I
felt resident evil was always a little
bit too action for me and then I played
with an evil 7 and fell in love
that game so good I wish I could play in
VR I'd love to try out and beer but this
was amazing as well I love they have
gone back to their kind of survival
horror boots and even though I'm not
really a like an action shooter type
gamer I really like it it's a great mix
of action and suspense and the fact that
you were going through the same
scenarios but with different people at
first I thought it was gonna be
extremely tedious and there are parts of
it that are but the fact that they've
even thought about how to mix it up a
bit in a sense that the zombies and the
creatures that you're attacking are in
different environments and the kind of
jump scare bits are completely different
it just it keeps you on your toes and
even though you knew the environment you
might be able to run around that more
you're never too sure what's around the
corner
so yeah it was great I loved this was a
good game really enjoyed it and now it's
time